blague non c'est que l'accent devait pas
un riz qu on est sur les bords du nil
vrai vous êtes vous êtes non seulement
chanteur vous êtes aussi très très drôle
enrico donc j'aimerais pour est ce que
vous nous avez préparé une petite blague
parce qu'ils ont tous préparé une blague
à la façon enrico ici on entendra la
mine a plus il ya je vous le dis elle
nous racontera une petite blague c6 et
enrico ce que vous en avez une
à nous raconter et on verra s'ils sont
plus drôles ou moins drôle que vous
allez alors c'est un un type qui va voir
son docteur c'est le docteur bénéchou
d'accord je connais rentrer dix ou onze
jours il parle comme ça mon bonjour
docteur minganie bien calmes à dieu oui
je vais bien et vous vous êtes vous êtes
là pourquoi il fait vite il ya soixante
patients qui attendent là écoutez j'ai
un problème
voilà ma femme ne veut plus faire
l'amour avec moi dit alors mais je sais
pouvoir faire bien vous n'avez qu'à lui
parler du cuche est pas finie vous vous
foutez de moi déjà que je parle du nez
voix
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
à lecteur à l'effet alors attention ils
ont tous préparent une blague mais il
faut faire avec l'action dell rico tout
ça on va démarrer avec isabelle morini
bosc
il faut il faut être plus drôle kendrick
au d'accord pour ça va être dur parce
que elle était très les abeilles morini
bosc qui pourrait vous en avez deux donc
à l'isie on vous écoute comme t'as pas
la première histoire en jeu droit on
n'en peut plus il ya camille combal
qu'attend il arrive à 20h 55m et revenir
c'est pas une histoire et c'est une
histoire de soutien à monsieur ils
viennent de gagnac sans ces ingrédients
pour le pôle privé millions d'euros
l'attend au frère et l'a dit amel en
euros
c'est chouette alors il ouvre la fenêtre
il voit sa femme commencé comme ça qu'on
voit sa femme chérie on avait nié
millions d'euros l'attend elle lui dit
j'attends pas démuni par amar qu'il
passe est vrai qu'une dame et il
m'arrivait oh [ __ ] quand c'est une
bonne journée c'est une bonne journée
[Applaudissements]
pas mal
c'était là sauf que là q vous en avez
une plume mois sauf que vous nous
racontera je vais choisir de vous avez
une bonne ouïe alesi un taxe en débat
allez on y va
c'est dans un laboratoire de recherche
où il ya un patron pieds-noirs et son
employé pieds-noirs et le patron dit à
l'employé j'avoue me trilles et les rats
là tu mets les rats femelles dans une
caisse
les rats mâles dans une autre caisse
pour demain et le lendemain le patron
revient il ya trois caisses alors que
j'ai beaucoup il ya trois caisses mais
il ya les femelles il ya les mâles et
les rapatrier
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quelques animaux là là quelle race rat
penat il vous en avez loupé avait
d'ailleurs choisi alors c'est david qui
va chez le docteur et bah voir un
docteur et deux paires je suis malade tu
malade je suis pas bien d'ailleurs
d'aucuns et des bombes à 10,33 david i
fé 30 30 30
on aurait dit je t'ai dit de dire 33 du
midi trente ans que d'habitude nous fait
10%
[Rires]
christian et c'est à vous les voulez
tenter ou ouais j'en ai malaisie la
baballe en a une petite blague de la
chaise non elle n'est pliante
c'est bien c'est la même c'est la même
bande
alors on va terminer par vous gilles non
non non mais relaxant mais vous avez une
blague non gecko l'accent un riz qu on
est sur les bords du nil voir
[Applaudissements]
comment tu m' pas donc tu me parles tu
as mis l'accent qu'il allait zabel alors
elle est un petit peu olé olé alors rico
recourir au mas de boulogne à la dame a
dit à son mari chéri ce serait bien pour
faire une petite gâterie
mais il fait très froid et le mari lui
dit ah non je me sens pas humainement je
ne sens pas la petite gâterie je le sens
pas et lui dit oui je sais tu as peur tu
as pas question tout petit
enfin non il jack j'ai surtout peur tu
claque des dents
[Rires]
ah ah
[Musique]